le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur jeudi 3 octobre
monsieur le ministre
l'inimaginable s'est produit au coeur de
la préfecture de police
frappé par de l'intérieur je voudrais
tout d'abord m'incliner devant la
douleur des familles leur exprimer ma
solidarité et saluer au nom de mes
collègues sénateurs le sacrifice des
victimes
aurélia tri firo damien ernest anthony
lancelot brice le mesquin et permettant
permettez moi d'abord moi aussi une
pensée pour nos amis allemands
victime d'une attaque la 2e attaque
d'une synagogue monsieur le ministre
j'aimerais que nous puissions nous en
tenir aux faits et comprendre ce drame
gravissime
depuis 2015 des dizaines d'attentats ont
été déjouées grâce aux services de
renseignements je souhaite saluer le
travail de nos forces de l'ordre
mais comment un membre de ces services
at il pu prendre pour cible ses
camarades
comment un terroriste at il pu
travailler dans un lieu dont la mission
est celle d'identifier les individus
dangereux
cet attentat implique de surcroît un
informaticien qui disposait de l'accès à
un nombre important d'informations
sensibles à quel fichier avait t-il
accès avez vous identifié ses contacts
en france à l'étranger
quelle protection et mise en oeuvre pour
les petits ce policier potentiellement
en danger
j'aimerais saluer à ce sujet le travail
de la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement et du président cambon qui
préside cette délégation et qui
contribuent à cette affaire monsieur le
ministre vous n'avez rendu père service
à personne en répétant le mantra
quelques heures après les faits il n'y a
ni faute ni dysfonctionnement ni anglais
mort vous expliqué avoir dit la vérité
des éléments connus au moment où vous
vous exprimiez mais aviez vous
interrogez le srt ou la dgsi placés sous
votre tutelle pour savoir si l'auteur
des faits était connu de leurs services
n'aurait-il pas été plus prudent de vous
en tenir à la compassion et au constat
de la gravité de la situation le
phénomène de radicalisation existe au
sein de l'administration dans des
secteurs stratégiques
devront être en capacité d'écarter ces
personnes radicaliser pour tous d'une
idéologie claire celle de détruire notre
société démocratique et les valeurs
qu'elle représente